liebe zuschauer unser erster goldener
vollpfosten geht an den präsidenten
donald trump denn große männer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jede nacht um halb eins schmeiße ich
twitter und beweise dass ich schütze
ganz alleine kann bald rede ich hier das
land denn dann bin ich präsident gibt
sich wahlversprechen wenn ich finde
nennt es gibt herr optik und krisen und
die scharia
doch zum glück hab ich die brüste von
melania ich baue eine mauer um die ganze
welt und im käfig und muslime den ich
haben das geld
s
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann ich machen
wenn ich könig von buschehr
a
das alles
und noch viel mehr
kann ich machen
wenn ich könig von hus wer
jeder trottel mit einer waffe kriegt von
mir ne norden bis zu passiv ist lass ich
dich wort geworden
glaubst du an den klimawandel bist du
terrorist kommst du mir dann mit fakten
bin ich angepisst
ich muss sie sich makros und atomraketen
mein fitnessprogramm meist mexicana
treten gleich zahle keine steuern die
fanden auch ich abtreten und bin nicht
richtig voll dann bei dierig die
schienen
das alles und noch
vielmehr
gar nicht machen
wenn ich könig von mussawi
das alles und noch viel mehr
kann ich machen
wenn ich könig von st
b
[Musik]
[Applaus]